même sous le soleil d'hiver le
vieux-port au regard de ses allures de
carte postale
marseille la cosmopolite offre aux
visiteurs sa bonne humeur
sa douceur aussi
mais sur les rives de la méditerranée se
reflètent également l'autre visage de
l'agglomération
plus sulfureux à 5 minutes de voiture en
créant pleine ville voici les quartiers
nord le lieu de tous les trafics
depuis la voie rapide il est déjà
possible de les apercevoir immobile
emmitouflés afin de passer la nuit
dehors des guetteurs à pau les chauffe
dans le jargon censé prévenir toute
intrusion dans leur quartier
à la science et des chaussures à moto et
passe pour signaler donc à présent ses
véhicules j'espérais véhicules de police
au volant gilles tachon ancien policier
il a travaillé 25 ans au pied de ces
tours avec la brigade anticriminalité
l ai mis une fois entrés dans la cité un
autre guetteur
vous ne l'entendrez pas sur ces images
mais il pousse alors un cri pour
prévenir de notre arrivée j'ai entendu
crier le mec tous phares éteints un
véhicule nous prend alors on chasse il
nous escorte jusqu'à la sortie de la
cité
rien ne doit perturber la juteuse vente
de drogue qui se déroule au pied des
tours un trafic qui a changé de mains
aujourd'hui ce sont deux jeunes très
jeunes trafiquants qui se livrent une
guerre acharnée pour chaque point de
vente
avant c'était tenu de main de fer par
des gens plus ou moins dans pas
respectable je dirais mais enfin qui à
la teneur à tenir leurs troupes
maintenant c'est fini à plus de
territoire et a plus rien du tout chacun
fait ce qu il en vit comme une envie est
d'accord il fera parler
des armes c'est tout ça se règlera coup
de kalach résultats des règlements de
comptes en série une trentaine recensée
en 2011 rien qu'en décembre il ya eu
cette fusillade dans ce snack un mort un
blessé
ensuite un homme de 17 ans abattu à la
kalachnikov dans une cage d'escalier
quatre jours plus tard trois jeunes
hommes de 19 ans a battu puis brûlé dans
cette voiture est finalement un véhicule
est pris pour cible au fusil d'assaut
deux personnes de 18 et 23 ans sont
gravement blessés au total 14 personnes
tuées en un an et des habitantes
déboussolés par cette violence dans ce
centre social au coeur d'une cité
cette maman vient rechercher sa petite
fille après sa journée de travail et
celle de son fils de 10 ans elle a
choisi de le mettre en internat pendant
la semaine loin de la cité
j'ai fait un choix pour mon petit garçon
puis c'est pour lui aussi parce qu'elles
influencent vraiment
mais non mon petit s'il va faire du vélo
ben je serai dehors avec lui jusqu'à 16h
16h30 je ne serai pas mon fils faire du
vélo seul dans la cité la peur pour ses
enfants
parce que tous aient deux jours je pense
que ma génération
quelle qu'elle soit peut que se faire du
souci pour ses enfants
est ce que les habitants connaissent
dans les quartiers nord semble
aujourd'hui touché l'est de marseille
cette cité du 11e arrondissement était
réputé paisible selon le maire du
secteur avant de connaître sa première
fusillade il ya dix jours
la délinquance s'étend à certains
endroits et elle se réduit à d'autres
moi ce que je veux pas c'est qu'on vient
de toucher des cités qui jusqu'à présent
étaient relativement tranquille et
sereine la cité d'à côté n'a pas connu
de fusillades à ce jour en revanche
beaucoup de voitures ont brûlé et des
armes de guerre ont fait leur apparition
quand on a fait les travaux sur le côté
là où les travaux commencés à 5h30 le
matin qu'un certain de la cité gens
sortent ils ont tiré en l'air la
kalachnikov fichiers ou où sommes-nous
quoi en faire arrêter les travaux pour
faire arrêter les travaux ça commençait
trop tôt bien sur eux il s'était couché
à 4h 5h du matin l'art on a dépassé tout
entendement des délinquants vont du fou
par des sommes d'argent colossales
la police a mis la main sur le carnet de
compte d'un dealer retrouver dans les
caves d'un immeuble nous avons
reconstitué ce bloc notes où l'on peut
lire que la vente de drogue sur un mois
à rapporter 161 1250 euros moins les
frais de fonctionnement du réseau les
bénéfices pour un seul point de vente
s'élève à 110 mille neuf cent cinquante
euros par mois dans ce carnet on apprend
également combien sont payés les uns et
les autres un guetteur 200 euros par
jour la nourrice celle qui cache la
drogue à son domicile
4775 euros par mois le gérant du réseau
en poche lui 9000 euros par mois des
entreprises ultra rentable
que les forces de l'ordre tentent de
décourager
depuis deux semaines nos descentes de
police par jour à chaque fois dans un
quartier différent tout est passé au
peigne fin à la recherche d'armes et de
drogue ces opérations ont le mérite de
les déstabiliser c'est pour les obliger
à commettre des erreurs bien évidemment
et à partir du moment où ils sont
obligés de déplacer les armes et des
produits stupéfiants on a encore plus de
chances de trouver en quinze jours un
pistolet automatique une kalachnikov et
plusieurs fusils à pompe ont été saisis
ainsi que 18 kilos de haschich plusieurs
personnes ont aussi été interpellées
il y à 150 sites et dans l'agglomération
marseillaise selon la préfecture une
source sûre est aujourd'hui gangréné par
ce nouveau banditisme
[Musique]